Who am I I am a generic web dork I I
talk and record about reverse
engineering breaking JavaScript web
applications things like that and
director of engineering at shape
security Google developer expert and if
you've ever played Starcraft or fallout
way back in the day and broke any of
those you might have been using my tools
built a lot of hacks for old games and
that's that's what got me into
programming way back in the day so shape
first of all as a name that you probably
don't know most people have no idea what
shape is we're not cool like Twitter or
github we're not making games or
anything crazy but if you ever heard of
YKK it's a company that all of you have
used their product but no one knows the
company they make virtually all zippers
in the world you check all your clothing
right now you probably see YKK on a some
some of your zippers all comes from one
company shape is the YKK of security you
don't know us but we're everywhere
you've probably used you've actually
probably run code that I once wrote
today and you almost definitely used it
when you were getting here so we are we
are relevant but we're kind of
underneath the surface we basically make
it so you don't see CAPTCHAs anymore so
event stream how it happened all started
with a packaged event stream event
stream was one of the earlier packages
created in the node.js ecosystem that
leveraged node streams and node has
gotten fairly popular over the years
when you're in early packages early
package using part of the core
architecture you're going to explode in
popularity so event stream was just a
way to makes using streams a little bit
easier for people who aren't aren't very
familiar with it so as of right now it
has over 1,500 direct dependence and as
you spiral out from there it just
explodes over time and it's downloaded
over 1.2 million times every single week
so event stream was maintained by
developer Dominic Tarr he creates a lot
of code and a lot of people depend on a
lot of what he's written he's not a
no-name developer a lot of people
respect them he's a good guy
and he does a lot of value
work he's got a very very substantial
following and he writes a lot of code
that people depend on hundreds upon
hundreds of repositories as packages and
one day last year September of 2018 he
gave this package event stream to a
random person now why would somebody do
that a lot of people who develop
open-source have a dream of someday
having a package that gets remotely
close to as popular as event stream why
would he give something like that away
and luckily he actually just posted why
he did that online and the gist of it is
he didn't want it anymore and somebody
asked for it
and that's ok when you've released code
online you shouldn't be expected to
maintain it for the end of time it's fun
at the start but eventually it starts to
suck a lot and for somebody who has
hundreds and hundreds of repositories if
you get somebody who wants to maintain
one success sure absolutely take it
please and that's what happened here so
right 9 control started to make some
relatively innocent changes updated
dependencies event stream hadn't been
used in a while and normal stuff added
some documentation added some examples
all stuff that looked very normal for
somebody maintaining a package nothing
major nothing that would draw attention
and then on September 9th 2018 right 9
control added a new dependency flatmap
dash stream and then released version 3
3 6 of event stream so about that carrot
everyone no semantic versioning should
this is this is a this is the room that
shouldn't know semantic versioning in a
talk like this but for anyone who's not
entirely up to speed semantic versioning
is the number number number versioning
scheme that a lot of projects use and
it's very very prevalent in node based
projects
the numbers are decrease are supposed to
decrease in risk so as your patch
version increases should just be buck
the bug fixes as your minor version
increases it should be features that
don't affect the core functionality of
what already exists when you bump a
major version that's when something
changed and you have to be more wary
about it so semver pattern matching is
for basically the ease of updating
dependencies the carrot until them means
something special to NPM and when you
specify a dependency by using it tilde
or caret you're basically saying I'm
okay with updating these dependencies as
long as it falls within this range of
risk which is generally a good thing
mostly updating dependencies is
something you want to do and if it
doesn't break anything that's good
unfortunately though with what we're
talking about updating dependencies all
the time comes with a lot of problems so
write nine control then removed flatmap
stream and then released event stream
400 now a note here nothing malicious
has emerged this is all looking
relatively normal and even the the last
removal of flatmap stream and the update
that also seems kind of normal exposed a
new API then realized didn't want to
expose it removed it updated the major
version that that's not not crazy so
time between first commit and version
4.0 was 12 days so on October 5th 2018
31 days after ownership changed in event
stream a new version of flatmap stream
was published 0.11 event stream 3 3 6
installed fresh now pulls in this
updated dependency because of that
carrot event stream 3 3 5 was stable for
2 plus years and a lot of things
depended on event stream with a carrot 3
3 5 so as soon as anything that depended
on event stream basically in the world
updated or installed dependencies fresh
it would pull in that updated flat map
stream dependency so the time between
malicious control and discovery was 77
days time between flatmap streams 0 1 1
and 0 dot 1.1 and discovery was 48 days
so 0 1 1 was the first introduction of
malicious code and was in the wild
before anyone noticed for over a month
and a half on a project that was
downloaded 1.2 million times a week I
think it was about 8 million developers
downloaded this package over the over
its lifespan so first off
what did it do first how actually did it
just how was it discovered in the first
place this is this entire story is one
of those things that's just fantastic
because it's like a Hollywood set up
everything everything works so well and
plays so nicely off each other
so the first payload in flatmap stream
used the method that was deprecated in
note 1100 it was deprecated in version
10 but it was just documentation
deprecation as soon as 1100 hit then it
started getting at you started getting a
console log or a warning in the in the
terminal note 11 was released 18 days
after flatmap zero-one-one was released
so now unrelated projects started to get
warnings of this deprecated method that
deprecated method was a method in the
crypto library a lot of projects
shouldn't be touching crypto libraries
so this was a warning that started to
raise some red flags and eventually
falling snow opened up an issue on event
stream basically wondering what the
hell's going on something weird is going
on it looks like there's this malicious
dependency I'm getting a warning and
node Mon this doesn't look right so how
was it discovered dumb luck in
coincidence there's no reason this would
have been discovered otherwise had there
not been that warning it had already
been lying low for a month and a half
even piecing it together at the end
required some work if people just
updated the event stream dependency to
400 that warning would have gone away
and I think that's probably what the
actor was hoping for by releasing it
that way people would just get past
something like that and they would just
move on and you wouldn't have to worry
about that dependency so flatmap stream
zero 1.0
this you also notice something weird to
the start it's an odious dependency it's
minified that's actually just something
that we as a community have gotten used
to we're just it's normal you do
download distributable x' and they might
be minified it might be all sorts of
weird transpilation artifacts so we're
already looking at code that we can't
really easily read flat map stream 0 1 1
just
like this it has 352 bytes added to the
end of it this is the first payload so
payload a this is the bootstrapper this
is what runs in order to enable the rest
of the the payloads this is what it
looks like prettified cleaned up a
little bit and flattened and removing
some of the the fluff there it looks
like this so at the start we have a
function that i've renamed unhex because
i was doing is taking a hexadecimal
string and translating into something
that you can read the first thing that
actually runs here is an unhex on just a
literal spring inside the code we can do
that by hand and we can see that it is
requiring an external file called test
data test slash data Jas this was
present in the malicious payload and
it's just a list of strings so these are
all the hexadecimal strings the first
two are very very large I've cut them
there and when you try to unhex them you
just get binary data they're not that
useful for us right now
the rest of the stuff though is pretty
useful to see you get crypto you get NPM
or our NPM package description and a yes
you can tell why the actor wanted to
obfuscate this stuff because if you saw
these literal strings in random code it
would set off some warning flags right
away so after rewriting payload a and
shifting out some of our replacing some
of those strings we get this code and
we're gonna go through it line by line
first step here what we already went
over we're importing test data and into
a variable called test data because why
not
next step here we are getting something
from the environment
NPM package description which is the
description from the package that Jason
and we are using that as the key to
create a decipher instance next step
here we are decrypting the first element
in test data so those big strings I was
talking about before and the test data
file we're decrypting that first string
there next up we're creating an instance
of a node.js module ignore the past
thing and then we are
taking the decrypted data and then using
that as the source for this module and
then we are exporting from that module
the second element in the test data so
going back to this top up there we can't
do anything else unless we find this key
this one's an important one and we're
not gonna be wearable I'm not gonna be
going through and brute-forcing what
could be a massive massive range just
adjust to decrypt this this was just one
of those fun little things I saw when
when it was happening and I was diving
into it it was very very easy for it to
drive me off track because reverse
engineering stuff like this very rarely
goes smoothly you get to a point where
you understand the gist of it and you
move on and you mitigate the problem so
here for anyone who this is an unrelated
package Jason so for anyone who's not
entirely familiar with the depths of NPM
it obviously manages your dependencies
but it also is a task runner if you've
ever used it to run tasks they are
defined in the scripts portion of the
package Jason they look like this they
are just keys in a script property and
then a list of commands that you run so
this is how NPM run scripts and when you
run in a script via NPM it pulls in all
this data from the package jason and
puts it into the environment so what
we're looking for here is an NPM script
that is that has a description that can
be used as a key to decrypt the first
element in that test data so to recap
this script decrypt and compiles a new
module that key to decrypt that module
comes from a package description
somewhere in the world
that encrypted the JavaScript comes from
the first element and then it exports
the second element so what this means in
in plain English is that we need to find
we this script will only do what it
needs to do if it is run as an NPM
script in a directory that has a package
Jason that has a description that will
properly decrypt that first element so
what this means for
us is that we need to go through a ton
of packaged Aysen files now where do you
get the largest repository of
package.json files you go to npm and
luckily and conveniently for us there is
a package called all the packages which
allows you to consume the package
metadata as a stream and go through it
one by one and yes of course it depends
on event stream so when you're dealing
with malicious code stuff like this and
you're trying to investigate you
probably shouldn't be doing it on your
main computer because we don't know what
this code is doing might be very very
malicious chances are though that we've
already run it we're already in problem
state but just in general virtual
machines and burner laptops are useful
so a strategy through here is to iterate
through every single package that exists
in the NPM registry use the package
description to decrypt that data because
we are we know that the decrypted data
is being passed to the compiled method
of a module instance we know that it has
to be JavaScript because keys can
decrypt data and just end up with other
gibberish we're gonna want to take that
decrypted data and run it through a
JavaScript parser just to make sure it
parses as JavaScript so we don't have to
do anything visually or by hand now this
is the type of hail-mary that very
likely is not going to work this is just
the first obvious place to stew go in
order to see if we can get some clue as
to what is actually decrypting this this
file after 20 seconds the password pops
up on the screen and it was almost just
like one of those just those amazing
experiences as a security researcher
because now you unlock the rest of the
the experiment you get to keep on going
that's what I mean this is Hollywood
it's like almost everything was linking
together and allowing you to keep going
now of course it's targeting Bitcoin
because what doesn't target bit going at
this point it's relatively unexcited to
me because just it's I would expected
something more beautiful this was
targeting the co-pay - wallet a secure
Bitcoin wallet for you to keep all your
your your fancy crypto probably
shouldn't do it anymore though probably
should move to a different one but now
this means that we could also now
decrypt the next stage so the first
stage was the bootstrapper the second
stage is what's going to inject the
final stage into its destination
this is what we're looking at right here
we don't need to go through this line by
line it's doing a lot of the same stuff
but there are two things to focus on the
first line here that gets executed is
testing something in the execution
against the regex if that regex doesn't
pass then the script doesn't do anything
so we already know that we're targeting
a very specific package Jason and now
we're targeting a very specific way of
running this so it's looking for the
third the the second argument to a
command on the command line we already
know that we are being run as an NPM
script NPM scripts are run as NPM run
script the script name so what we are
looking for here is the script name that
is going to be targeted now because Co
paid well not quite yet so this
particular reg X is looking for build :
blah - release because co pay - is
luckily a open source application we can
look at the package Jason that was being
targeted now you can see here this build
: iOS - release and build : Android
release and build : desktop release if
you're familiar with the history of web
development and native applications
you'll also recognize cordova cordova
for those of you who aren't familiar is
PhoneGap by a different name basically a
hybrid development environment that
allows you to use web technology HTML
CSS and JavaScript on native
applications so we are targeting the
build step for co-pay Dash's application
being built by Cordova so this next line
here in payload B is poking deep into
the dependencies of co-pay - in order to
find a file that it knows co-pay - will
hydrate and run in a context that the
script wants to be running
so this this is not a malicious
dependency it's just a random file that
is that has depended on by copay - so
recap payload B doesn't do anything
unless we are being run in a very
specific build stage of co-pay Dash's
application it decrypts payload C the
same way that payload B was decrypted
and injects payload C into a dependency
of co-pays mobile application and then
payload C is then executed in the mobile
application context on a mobile users
device payload see the final payload it
was all I could do to not put a
reference to Europe in there so payload
C is this it's a lot longer we're not
gonna go through it but it's the final
payload and the final payloads of a lot
of these things are usually the least
least exciting it's everything that gets
you to where you want to be that's
exciting the code at the end is just
doing what you wanted to do in the first
place this is just standard web code
there's some document stuff local
storage stuff Ajax e stuff the gist of
it is it was harvesting private keys it
was targeting wallets that had at least
a hundred Bitcoin or a thousand Bitcoin
cache and it was sending all this data
up to a third party API server so where
does this leave us now this is not node
an NPM specific I know that you all are
probably perfectly okay believing that
but for everyone outside of this
ecosystem who points at us me like ha
you're a bunch of slobbering jerks who
do horribly insecure things and tear the
world apart you can point to them and
say no no this is actually a problem
everywhere we're just more popular than
you that's why things like this happen
so the good news is that as soon as this
this came to light the community rallied
around it instantly you had a bunch of
independent researchers with people like
me who reverse-engineer things and as
soon as they saw this they dropped
everything and tried to focus on it see
what's going on and then once it was
found out people were notified tools
were written in order to make sure that
it was mitigated or
you were able to detect whether or not
it affected you and and if it did to
mitigate whatever that effect is
the bad news is that it happened
literally again this week
if you've read your npm weekly or node
weekly whatever it was you'll you'll see
that NPM mitigated themselves this
problem for another Bitcoin wallet but
the problem is that it was the same
exact type of attack
it was the exploitation of a dependency
that was automatically updated and was
sucked into a target application and it
did whatever it needed to do to get what
it wanted this whole thing could have
been much much much much much worse
just in general event stream was
downloaded all over the world all over
the place and I have to imagine that the
the target was was obviously determined
in advance and as soon as the route in
was found the target was was just what
was focused on everything else was on
the side the scope of exploitation here
was so amazing though that I have to
imagine the actor probably regrets only
targeting such a small sliver of the
world
this was depended on by the azure CLI so
anyone who was using the azure cloud
platform had potential to be exploited
so anything you were deploying there had
potential to be infected dozens of build
tools basically everything gulp depended
on event stream so anything that was
built by gulp had the opportunity to be
infected and the code editor Monaco for
Visual Studio code dependent on event
stream so you didn't even have to be
bought into fully the nodejs NPM
ecosystem you just had to use Visual
Studio code and you might have had this
problem arise somewhere else
this was widespread and I guarantee that
basically every single one of us here
had this malicious code on our computers
at some point this is likely as a
problem going to get much much worse
there's there's a lot that needs to
happen in order to make sure that this
never happens again but unfortunately
these are hard topics that require lots
of changes lots of buy-in lots of
backwards-compatibility concerns and
every time those things come come up and
an opportunity arises to kind of just
step aside and let it fall to the floor
people will let it fall to the floor
because these are hard conversations
there are some conversations by
important people talking about some
strategies to evolve platforms in the
future one of the ways around that
Ryan doll is exploring with Dino so Ryan
doll is a creator of node a long time
ago regrets some of the things that are
in node now some of them are his choices
some of them are are their choices in
general there are things that he would
have preferred to do differently now
he's experimenting with some of those
concepts in Dino one of those concepts
is privileged API access the same type
of things that we use on mobile phones
like you you downloaded app I say I
allow this app to use GPS or whatever
else that uses GPS if you say no can't
use GPS or you don't download the app
something like that you could do that
with a lot of AP eyes that are
accessible in node IO access crypto
access if you're if you're using
dependencies like left pad they
shouldn't have access to all these
things so stuff like that is baked into
Dino so what can you do now
first off rethink dependencies audit
your dependencies lock your dependencies
check in your dependencies and I know
I'm pissing people off with some of
these and I'm sorry
think twice before adding any new
dependency when in doubt don't add it
every dependency you add is risk you're
adding to your application to your
company to you and risks or Gamble's you
only take a gamble if the cost is lower
than the value and if the value is high
then it's worth taking if the value is
low then you were just putting yourself
at risk for very very little value and
if you make those Gamble's over and over
and over again you're going to find
yourself in in pain so thank you very
much
[Applause]